Good morning, everyone. I would like to get this
session started, entitled,
"CAR-T Therapy: Transforming the Landscape of Adult and Pediatric
Blood Cancers."
My name is Steve Gottschalk, and I'm from St.
Jude Children's Research Hospital.
We're going to have three talks, first by Karina Patel, then by
Matthew Frank, and at the end by me.
Especially also for the folks online, the times are wrong.
I'm not going to have a 20-minute introduction.
So the first 30 minutes are dedicated to
Karina, the next 30 to Matt, and the last 30 minutes to myself.
So,
the first speaker, Dr. Patel, is an associate professor
and the multiple myeloma section chief in the Department of Lymphoma
and Myeloma at The University of Texas MD Anderson Cancer
Center, where she leads a clinical and translational research
program focused on improving outcomes for patients with multiple
myeloma and other plasma cell disorders through novel
immunotherapies such as CAR T-cell therapy and targeted agents.
And I'm just going to pull up her talk.
Here you go, Karina. You're
simple.
Thank you so much for the invitation to give this talk today.
And, I do all things myeloma, but I will say this is my favorite part.
CAR T-cell therapies have really changed the way we think of myeloma
in general. And so, it's actually the next 10
years I'm really excited about. So I'll talk a little bit about the idea
that when I started,
maybe a little over 10 years ago, even about a couple of years ago, we've
always thought of myeloma as a disease that you have to continuously treat.
You can't take the pressure off because the myeloma's going to come back.
We can't cure it. And so now we're thinking about it differently, and it has a lot
to do with our outcomes in CAR T. So we'll talk about incurable to potentially
curable, the evidence of that durability from our first-generation CAR
Ts that none of us thought were going to work the way they did, and it's been
fantastic to see. Then now we've learned, of course, there are certain biomarkers
and predictive markers that tell us which are the patients that do really well, and
who are the patients we need to do better for, and how do we clinically change
things, but also how do we change the CARs to make it better so more patients can
have that potential functional cure.
And then part of that is that next generation CAR design, why we're doing what
we're doing, and then what are the early results so far.
And then, of course, pathway to and cures the cure fraction.
And part of that is access, right? So 20% of our patients who can actually get CAR
T can come to my center or centers like ours, where they can get that CAR T.
And so how do we make it more accessible? Financial piece is one.
I'm not going to talk about that today, but it's important.
But really, how do we just make it easy to give?
And my last few slides are on a potential that could hopefully change things for
the future.
So here's the survival outcomes, just the last 60 years in myeloma.
I know most of you don't do myeloma in here, and so just to kind of give you that
idea of, in the 1960s, basically we had alkylators,
and patients had a survival of two years.
And then the 1990s, we finally got high-dose alkylators with transplant,
which really has changed things. And today, we still do those high-dose transplants
for the majority of patients, but median overall survival is still four to five
months from diagnosis. Then we had those novel agents, those proteasome
inhibitors, more targeted chemo.
We had the first sort of immunotherapy with IMiDs,
immunomodulatory drugs like lenalidomide.
And again, went up about a couple of years.
So average survival, five to seven years.
And then now we started combining all these things, especially with monoclonal
antibodies, our first true
immunotherapy. And again, eight to 10 years.
And now we don't have the full-on, but basically with CAR Ts and
bispecifics, where we're using T-cells, we're actually seeing an addition of
61 months in those really relapsed refractory patients.
So, I think we're going to hit 15 years and longer for a lot of these patients.
And of course, now we're going to the best therapies up front.
So we're going to hopefully see a big shift in these survival outcomes.
So what really changed for us was getting this target.
In myeloma compared to lymphoma, we had CD19.
We tried CD19 in myeloma thinking maybe there's some plasma cells that we can kill
or a stem cell myeloma cell that we can kill with CD19, but it didn't
work. And so this is from, basically in the early
2000s to 2010, a lot of people were looking at this target, but we just didn't know
what it did, if we could target it or not. And then Dr.
Anderson met Dana-Farber. Their lab really looked at
BCMA and how can we actually use it.
And in the end, we learned that it's involved in a lot of pathways for
proliferation and survival of myeloma cell.
And basically, all patients have it, from MGUS to smoldering to active
myeloma. Over 95% of patients and most of their clones
in their myeloma have BCMA to be targetable.
And that's why it became such a huge target for us.
So now we have not just CAR Ts, but we have bispecifics and ADCs
and KCARs, a lot of things going after this target because it really, really is
important in myeloma.
So coming to the actual CAR Ts. We have two approved CAR Ts for us
to use in clinic: ide-cel and cilta-cel. They are different.
Ide-cel was one of the first that we had.
It uses a traditional ScFv to go after that BCMA
versus cilta-cel. The big difference is it actually uses two
variable domain heavy chain antibodies.
And it actually goes to two different epitopes of BCMA.
In dosing and how it causes CRS, everything is different.
I'm not going to go into the clinical specifics, but they are different because of
those little changes that they have in the CARs themselves.
So coming to ide-cel, again, our first CAR T that was approved for myeloma.
The Phase 1 study, these are patients with six prior lines of therapy.
Again, overall survival would've been six months to a year for them.
Their overall response was about 72%, and PFS was 11.1 months.
That was huge for us at the time, but now you'll see the rest of these CARs where
we're seeing almost three years as a median PFS.
So this CAR T sort of is something we use for certain patient
populations, but maybe not everybody.
And then KarMMa-3 was our first Phase 3 study, and again, compared to our
monoclonal antibodies like daratumumab-based triplets, it was a
huge difference in that median PFS, which was basically 13.3 months
versus 4.4 months for our patients who got standard of care.
So all of a sudden, our standard of care, really low compared to what our CAR Ts
can do. So that was just a taste, and then I'm not going to go through these in
detail, but basically in that KarMMa-3, that Phase 3, a lot of our older
patients. So myeloma is a disease of older patients for the most part.
Average diagnosis age is 65 to 69. So again, we
have to make sure these therapies our patients can tolerate.And in our older
patients, especially over 70 and 75, even some of our
octogenarians, it has been really safe, and it's actually increased
survival by two to three years for them.
And so there's a lot of other studies between CIBMTR as well as um
US Myeloma Consortium, and one of my colleagues at MD Anderson who
looked at polypharmacy and comorbidities that really showed ide-cel is really
well-tolerated as well as helps our older patients get off
therapy. So coming off therapy for our patients, as I told you before, where we
continuously gave treatments has been such a big difference.
Our patients feel back to normal. They say they feel like they were
before they were ever diagnosed. So even for our older patients, I think that's
important. And then I'm coming to why we actually talk about cure in myeloma now.
So cilta-cel
was, again, these patients were 97 patients in
relapsed/refractory, had six prior lines of therapy, and the overall
response rate was 97%-98%, which is pretty phenomenal to have in
any as a single agent, in very relapsed/refractory patients.
But finally, last ASCO, we actually got this long-term data
of 33% of patients who were five years out without any
myeloma and still were in remission.
So we finally use the word remission now for our patients.
And again, for us, that's a functional cure that we didn't have, especially
in relapsed/refractory patients.
And so this is where we ended up having an actual meeting through our
IMS to talk about what is cure in myeloma.
And again, we're talking about patients who can be off therapy for five
years at least or longer. We're supposed to test for MRD to 10 to the
-6, and if they are negative every year.
And then, also immune reconstitution.
And that part is so important because we have amazing therapies besides CAR Ts out
there, but continuous therapy for any of those is not going to lead to immune
reconstitution versus with CAR Ts, we actually see that.
And so I won't talk about as much, but sequencing matters when you have immune
reconstitution versus not in terms of treatment.
Again, this is really important for our field and our group that we have this,
finally, to talk about. It'll help our
trials in the future really aim towards that cure rather than saying, "Okay, let's
just get a response and then keep them on treatment forever."
So who are the patients that get that really great response?
So CARTITUDE-4 was also a randomized study.
And basically here, the median PFS has not been
reached either for those patients who got standard of care or they got
cilta-cel. But what I wanted to show was the graphs that actually look at patients
who are high risk myeloma, so certain cytogenetic abnormalities or
patients with EMD. We have a whole group of patients that don't do as
well. That's what's called multiple myeloma, and they don't do as well as our
standard risk patients. And so the red are the patients who got cilta-cel,
and then the black are the ones who got standard of care.
As you can see, both groups do better with cilta-cel than with standard of
care. But the top line are those patients who have standard risk versus that bottom
red line are the ones who have high risk.
So again, we know that the genomics of that myeloma really does
matter in outcomes, even though this treatment still works better than the other
options we have. And again, you're seeing the PFS as well as the overall
survival for these groups. And we don't have the five-year data yet, but we do
think that there's going to be more patients who are in that functional cure when
they get CAR T earlier. So this was second, third, and fourth line rather than
after six lines. So again, proves that we really want early
line CAR T compared to late line.
And here's some other, I have some translational data I'll show, too.
But again, these are patients in bolded that had high-risk cytogenetics
versus extramedullary, high baseline tumor burden, and time from
last line of therapy to start. And really what it's showing is that first column
is those who got more than five years progression-free versus those that
were after five years, and this is back to the CARTITUDE-1, so those late line
patients. And what they're trying to show is that patients with high-risk disease
actually can get that five years even in late line.
But really what matters is how much disease they had going in, as well
as some of the translational data.
So again, patients who had better post-infusion E to
T ratios of their T cells. So the CAR positive CD4 positive T cells
actually did much better, more likely to get to that greater than five
years of remission compared to the patients who didn't.
So really that T cell product matters, and it's not just the
genomics, it's really how much myeloma we have going into the CARs, and what does
that T cell product look like when we're giving it.
And then I think a little different than lymphoma and leukemia, we have some unique
toxicity profiles because we go after BCMA.
There's a lot of data being looked into this, including translational, that we'll
have a lot of papers for soon. So I won't go into details, but
BCMA is on mature B cells and plasma cells, and so we see
significant hypogammaglobulinemia.
So infections, especially the first six months, are really important to try to
ameliorate, so we give IVIG to everybody, unlike others.
Delayed neurotoxicity. So again, there's this idea that maybe
BCMA is in certain parts of the brain,
that can actually be
a reason why there's about 5% of patients in the late line
trials and about 1% in the early line trials that got
Parkinsonism. So basically, really bad neurotoxicity there in
CRs, and we had no idea what was going on.
When you give better bridging therapy and there's less myeloma, that risk
goes down to, again, less than 1%. So we know that expansion of T cells is part of
it, so decreasing that tumor burden is so important.
And so now most of our patients go in when they've had a really good response to
bridging before they get their CARs to really decrease some of these side effects
we're seeing. And then nothing that was on the clinical trials, but in the real
world, we've seen some enterocolitis.
Basically in the duodenum, we'll see these CARs there, and again,
just horrible diarrhea where it's nine, 10 liters of diarrhea, not just a little
bit of diarrhea that we usually see.
Again, less than 5% of patients that we've seen this in, but we don't know exactly
what causes it. And so, again, there's three different centers that are looking at
that translational data, and we'll have
updates and papers soon. But there's a question, is this more of a clonal T
cell process that's causing this?
It does look like it's CARS that are going into the actual duodenum and GI
that's causing some of the side effects.
So we actually give Cytoxan or things like tacrolimus to kill those
cells to hopefully help with them improving
outcomes.Okay, so how can we now, next generation, how do
we do better? So there's another CAR T, Anita Cell,
that I got to present at ASH that actually uses a different ScFv.
So again, not the VHH, not the ScFv, but this is a D
domain. It's synthetic. It's a very small protein that
basically facilitates high transduction efficiency.
So most of their product is all CARs.
And then it also lacks tonic signaling.
And the other big thing is it comes off, so there's a fast off rate.
And so we think that maybe this is why there's less risk of major
toxicities. And response-wise, again, 96% responses,
greater than CR, stringent CR 74%.
We don't have a Kaplan-Meier curve yet, but it looks like at 24 months, about
61% of patients, 62% are still in remission.
So hopefully we'll see a tail, but we don't have it as of yet.
And then MRD data, again, the majority of patients that were evaluable were MRD
negative. And we only have six months sustained MRD, which again,
majority of patients still are. But really what I'm looking forward to is in the
next year, having that one year and two years.
So sustained MRD is a better prognostic
tool for us than just a one-time.
So then coming to how else can we improve outcomes for our patients?
So novel targets, we have GPRC5D. So again, before we
were jealous of the lymphoma doctors. They had CD19, we had nothing.
Then we got BCMA. Now we have GPRC5D.
We have others, FCRH5, and a whole bunch of other targets that
we're looking at in myeloma, which is exciting.
But GPRC5D, really, it's an orphan G protein coupled receptor.
It's highly expressed on myeloma cells.
Again, we see it in patients who are MGUS all the way to relapse refractory
myeloma. It's a little bit different. We don't see it on B cells.
It's usually mature plasma cells, and it's a little bit more like
CD19 in that you can have loss of GPRC5D a little bit
faster than BCMA. BCMA, we can have dimming of BCMA.
You can have mutations if you have chronic, if you're going after it chronically,
like with bispecific therapies or ADCs.
But we don't really see a loss the way we do with some CD19.
And so, again, GPRC5D is a little bit more like CD19 than that.
But it is very complementary to BCMA therapy.
And so the first CAR T that we have results for, here,
87% overall response rate in these patients who are very relapse
refractory. Many of these patients had prior BCMA therapies already in
that greater than three prior lines.
When you go a little bit earlier, and especially if patients haven't had BCMA
therapies, you see the response is 94%.
And then again, PFS goes from 18 to 24.3 months.
But still pretty impressive for a really, really relapse refractory patient group,
including those who have had prior BCMA therapy.
Okay, so then if we have one target, why not go after two?
And again, there's different ways you can make these CAR T cells.
You can have two different cells that are different CARs that go in with
co-administration. Or you can have co-expression of two vectors versus a
bicistronic vector versus a tandem CAR.
And I'll show you one of those that's a tandem CAR in a second.
But again, these are all the different targets that are being tested, BCMA and CD19
together, BCMA and CS1, as well as BCMA and
GPRC5D.
So here's the AZDO120 trial,
which is looking at CD19 and BCMA together.
And again, this is a tandem CAR that they use.
The thought process, there's two reasons this CAR is different.
One, CD19, again, thinking that maybe there are some
stem cell-like memory cells that have CD19.
There's some translational data that shows it.
I don't think everyone's convinced, but I will say there is definitely
some patients that have CD19 on their myeloma as well.
But the other piece is that their platform of manufacturing, which I'll show a
slide about, they can make the cells within 24, 48 hours, and
then they actually are done making the cells.
It takes about two weeks to get them because of
just making sure the in-spec qualifications that they have to do.
But again, these cells are not in
culture for very long, and so they're much more central memory T cell, central
memory cells. They have a lot less of LAG-3, TIM-3,
all the checkpoint kind of inhibitors, and these cells just work very differently.
And for us, in clinic, we can actually tell there's a clinical difference
of how our patients do with these. So the biggest thing, the data in
China shows for relapse refractory patients, they've done it for a lot
longer. Their median PFS was 38 months.
So again, a little bit closer to cilta-cel. Looks pretty fantastic.
And in The US, we've only had 23 patients, and they presented this data at ASTCT
most recently. But 96% overall response rate, 94%
MRD negative. So I'm pretty sure we're going to see a great PFS down the road.
And again, the ICANS and CRS were much
lower with this product compared to what we see in our traditional
CARs. And then we don't see any of the neurotox or coli
GI symptoms. And then 35% of these patients were actually able to get this
outpatient, which is pretty fantastic.
As a clinical trial, I don't think we've reached that before.
And so again, here's that fast CAR next day manufacturing that they do.
So in vivo, activation transduction for about one to two days.
They do ex vivo expansion about five days for the most part, and then they give
us the cells. Usually, the cells are ready within two to three weeks.
So then if we have something that comes back to us so fast, which is important in
clinic, what about just doing allogeneic?
This question always comes up, and we've actually had CAR Ts for
allogeneic CAR Ts with different targets, CS1 and
others, for a while. It's just we haven't had anything that's worked well.
Or it's caused some significant side effects.
And so this one, CB-011, actually is
a CAR T. It's an allo CAR T that uses CRISPR gene editing.
It has this immune cloaking
as well that helps evasion from both NK and T cells, so hopefully we'll have better
persistence. And again, it's a BCMA therapy, so
92% overall response rate, 75% greater than CR,
91% MRD negativity, which is fantastic.
Now, our allo CAR Ts do require higher lymphodepletion for the
most part, which does lead to potentially increased infection risks, et
cetera. But I think being able to manufacture the cells where they're not going to
be cleared out by the immune system, hopefully will let us decrease some of that LD
chemo and decrease the side effects.
But again, they did receive that RMAT designation just
last month. So hopefully, maybe this will be our first allo CAR T that gets
approved. My last couple minutes, I'm going to talk about the future and something
that's really exciting.Why not just not make cells?
What if we can just give the vector to that patient directly?
And this, again, for access, if we can figure out how to do this well
and make it safe, this could actually change how people
around the world could get CAR T and not have to worry about that manufacturing at
all, not worry about LD chemo because they actually don't use LD chemo as of
right now with this either. So there's two in myeloma that have been
published. The ESO one, that was published in "The
Lancet" last June. And then, of course, we had a late-breaking abstract in
myeloma that was presented at ASH, this last ASH.
And again, this is an envelope modified,
self-inactivating lentiviral vector, and it's de-targeted
with the fusogen to avoid delivery to LDL-expressing cells.
But they still have a high transduction efficiency, which is really important.
It does really go after T-cell retargeting in terms of that
CD3-scFv, so it avoids liver uptake and drug
sinks. And then, of course, it's anti-BCMA for this
version of this CAR.
So they've had four patients that they've talked about, so it's not a lot of
patients as of yet. I know they have a lot more now going on.
But again, relapse refractory patients, two different dose levels that they've
tried so far. Most of these patients have had a prior auto and lots of
refractoriness to other therapies, including anti-CD38s.
And what they were able to see is that not having lymphodepletion chemo, they were
still able to have these T cells
expand within these four patients.
And what's interesting is that also a little bit different than in lymphoma,
and I don't know about leukemia as much, but we actually see our T cells
expand with their ALCs. So with cilta-cel, for instance, many of our patients will
have an increase in their ALC in that first 14, 21 days that tells
us these T cells are going out. We've actually tried to see if that was related to
toxicity or not and decreasing those count levels.
And so far, it hasn't looked like it's worked.
But here, this patient had up to 40,000
ALC, but it did come right back down, and most of these were CAR
positive, and I'll say persistent memory CAR T cells that they've seen at least
till month three. So this is where that LD chemo question, and I'll see over time
what happens. In myeloma, we say we don't need persistence for
CAR T PFS to be great. But I think, again,
when these are potentially not having any lymphodepletion, I want to see what
happens long-term for these patients.
And then again, ongoing MRD negative responses.
And this is why we say persistence doesn't matter, because we kill so much of the
myeloma in the first 30 days that we think it just takes a little
bit longer for it to ever come back.
But I think that persistence question still remains.
And so with that, I just wanted to give my take-home messages.
So really, the current CAR Ts are which CAR T is right for which
patient. Earlier is definitely better.
We really need to go on beyond BCMA and with combinations.
Next generation looks phenomenal and hopefully will improve access.
And really our goal is to go to that majority cure fraction in the next
10 years. With that, thank you so much.
Thank you for this great talk. It's now open for questions.
If there's no one, I have one.
Okay.
What is the prospect of moving CAR T-cell
therapy up front
for multiple myeloma?
Fantastic question. So we actually have two studies that have already been done,
CARTITUDE-5 and 6, that have been enrolled.
We don't have any data as of yet. I was not a part of those studies, so I can't
give any information anyway. But I think it's looking at one
of the trials, CARTITUDE-6 is looking at versus transplant, because
again, most of our patients currently do get transplant as consolidation.
And then CARTITUDE-5 is just looking at patients who either don't want transplant
or are ineligible and seeing those outcomes.
Again, MRD data looks so phenomenal in really relapse refractory
patients that I think we're going to get 100% MRD level
data in upfront if we do CAR Ts up front.
It's going to come down to toxicity and
cost, I will say, in terms of uptake, but I do think it's going to beat it in
efficacy. And what's different with these trials is we're trying to
actually stop maintenance. So as of today, with auto
transplant, we go to maintenance dara and len for a lot of patients,
and we only stop if they're MRD for two years, but they continue the len until
progression. So I think, again, a way to stop treatment for our
patients is what the CAR Ts will help us do even in front line.
Thank you.
I have one other question. Yeah, go ahead, please.
Great talk. Thank you.
So I have a question about Allo CB-011,
right?
Can you speak into the microphone?
Oh, sorry. I have a question about Allo product
CB-011, right? So this is
with immune cloaking. I'm wondering how long the CAR T
cells can persist in the patient, and what's the peak
compared to autologous case?
Yeah.
Thank you.
No, fantastic question. And I will say on not just this CAR T, but all of
our Allos, they've had a harder time persisting.
They're going to present an updated data set, hopefully this year in
2026, but as of right now, I know that most of their
CARs do disappear, just like
cilta-cel technically disappears after three to six months.
Most of their CARs are gone usually after three months.
But again, I don't have the updated data for all their patients.
And it comes down to that persistence question.
Is it important in myeloma or not? I think it's important still.
Even if it's not in the peripheral blood, I do think that we see CAR Ts in other
tissues and bone marrow. And so how do we test for that is another question.
But I agree with you. In Allo, that persistence might make a bigger
difference than in auto CARs.
Hi. Fantastic. That was great, especially catching up on things that I've
missed.
So I had one question around for the relapse after CAR
BCMA and the combo therapies. As you pointed out, they
don't lose the antigen necessarily like they do in lymphoma CD19.
I had the privilege of working with Al on the CD19 BCMA at Penn.
We didn't get better responses combining it with our hypothesis.
So what do you think is the hypothesis for what's driving the relapse when the
antigen's still there, the antibodies still bind, and then we retreat with the same
product and nothing happens?
Yeah. Fantastic question. I actually talked to Al about the CD19 part just
last week when we were at a conference together.
So I was thinking of him when I said that. But, so I agree with you.
If we're not losing BCMA, which again, 5% of patients will lose BCMA
after CAR T, a little bit less than 5%, especially our patients who
have
TP53 17p deletion, because 16p is right next to it, and
that's where BCMA is expressed. So there are some that lose it.
But if patients get more than two, three years
from their CARs, it looks like they do respond to
BCMA CARs again. So,
none of the trials-- Well, the trials allow for prior BCMA, some,
so that DURGA study with CD19 BCMA, there's a small cohort that allowed
that. None of the other trials did.
And in the real world, insurance won't pay for two BCMAs.
But when we've gotten it, because someone either changed insurance and they didn't
know, or they were on a trial, and then we were able to get a commercial, it was
100% response rate for that small group of patients.
So if they get a certain amount of time, they do much better.
It's if they relapse within that first year or so, that one
with the same CAR T, we think there could be some antibodies.
Again, no one's been able to prove it, but a different CAR T actually does work
when the same one on the trials didn't.
But we just don't have enough data to really say, "Could I treat again?
If someone gets five years, can I treat again, and is it going to work?" It
might. So I think with BCMA, it's a little tricky.
Now, if you do bispecifics for a long time, we do see
mutations. And then you have to know if that ScFv or that
DDOM, whatever you're going to use, is going to attach that mutated BCMA.
And again, we don't have any data on that.
So I think there's a few different ways that patients might not respond,
but there's just not as much data that shows that patients do respond if we get
them in that right scenario.
Yeah. Hi. Great presentation. In terms of thinking about
T-cell engagers, can you comment on T-cell engagers prior to
CAR and how you think about sequencing?
Yeah, no. Great question and
our biggest dilemma right now in myeloma.
So,
I think, and I will say Penn, Al Garfall actually gave
a great discussion on maybe when we're doing bispecifics
early line, that will change things.
Most of our data's from late line. So these patients, they'll get a year from their
bispecifics, and then we're trying to go to CAR.
They've already had all this therapy.
Just the logistics of trying to get their CAR made becomes a big deal.
So we can't actually-- There's a lot of manufacturing
fails because they've just had so much therapy.
Now they've been on a T-cell engager this entire year, and then you're trying to
make CARs, right? We're setting it up to fail.
Early line, now that we have the MajesTEC-3 data, we have Techdara
up front. What are we going to do because a lot of patients are going to get this
in the community where they can't get CAR.
I'm hoping that what we'll be able to show is fixed duration Tech
or Elra or any of our bi-- Lynvo, all of our bispecifics.
I'm hoping that fixed duration can show that we can take patients off
therapy, so that way, when they do relapse, hopefully it's been a few, maybe
years, and then we can actually-- Those T-cells are better, as well as maybe
we won't have the mutations in that BCMA.
The big unknown is the mutation, the BCMA mutations that I worry about
if people are on a bispecific or even an ADC for a really long time.
I worry we're trying to cause resistance for CAR.
So as of today, I still give CAR first because I have
access to everything. It doesn't mean you shouldn't do a bispecific if a
patient can't get to a CAR because it's amazing data.
But I'm hoping that the bispecific world, we're going to start doing fixed duration
instead, and then the sequencing won't be as big of an issue.
And if I do use a bispecific first, I try to go for the GPRC5D
one,
just to make sure I have BCMA still there.
All right. Let's give Dr. Patel another round of applause.
Thank
you.
Can you help me? Oh, F star. Let's see. All right.
Good. So our next speaker is Dr. Matt
Frank. He's an assistant professor of medicine in the Division of
Blood and Marrow Transplantation and Cellular Therapy at Stanford
University.
He takes care of high-risk lymphoma patients and has
a particular interest in CAR T-cell therapies beyond
targeting CD19 and identifying
predictors of relapse and toxicity post-CAR T
treatments.
Good morning, everyone. Thank you for coming at this early hour.
I want to thank the organizers for the invitation to speak.
So I was given this daunting task of trying to talk about all the emerging
approaches in both leukemia and lymphoma for CAR.
So I apologize to those who are working on things that I couldn't include.
But I've tried to create a slide set that includes as many things as possible.
Here are my disclosures.
I always want to just take stock of where we're at.
This is an impressive list. This is a lot of patients who volunteer for clinical
trials. We have many, many now FDA-approved
options. We've heard about the two options in myeloma from Dr.
Patel. Phenomenal talk, so thank you.
But we also now have some newer approvals.
So as of December of last year, we now have a lyso cell now
approved for marginal zone lymphoma.
So this is an impressive list.
This dates back to 2017, so we've come a long, long way.
But we also know that there are reasons that CAR T-cells fail, and I'm going to
start with lymphoma. And so, we can see
durable CR rates, depending if it's third
line or second line or first line,
between 30% to 50%. In front line, it can be as high as
70%.But we know that after you relapse,
your outcomes are poor. So this is data from one of many
groups who publish now in this space that after you've progressed with large cell
lymphoma,
your median survival is under six months.
Now, with bispecifics, that might be a little bit longer, but it's not a full year
yet. We're talking about very dismal outcomes.
And one of the reasons that patients relapse is CD19 is lost
or decreased or in some cases mutated.
So here's an example that we had at Stanford.
You can clearly see that they had a wonderful response, but now the disease is
roaring back with no CD19 expression.
So target something else. Pretty obvious, but it's actually a bit more
complicated. So these are just a few of the
targets that have been attempted in lymphoma.
And we have certainly two approvals now that have these
two different construct designs that target CD19.
But now we are starting to have other designs that are being heavily tested, both
the tandem bispecific and the bispecific bicistronic.
Both of these now target CD19, CD20. I'll show you that data in a moment.
But there are groups who have developed a trispecific tricistronic or a tandem
trispecific or a trispecific bicistronic.
And these are fun words to say, but it's basically just designing different
ways of targeting different antigens and then having signals transduced through
various mechanisms.
These are in the clinic. This is not, but the concept is here.
We basically want to target multiple antigens
or alternative antigens.
So those are the three most common in lymphoma, but certainly there are others
emerging.
But it's not so simple. There have been some CAR T-cell crashes.
So we saw an anti-CD20 that showed a lot of promise in indolent lymphoma.
However, the trial's on hold. I think other things have emerged and it's not
moving forward.
I was heavily involved with a CD22 CAR that was developed by Cargo, and I can get
into the details why it didn't go so well, but it had poor durable
remissions and had high rates of IECHS and HLH-like
toxicity that led to five patients passing away.
So we had to halt that trial.
There was a anti-ROR1 CAR that, again, another
good target, but there was a death in the first six, and that trial has been on
hold.
And then CD37 is found on T cells, on B cells, but the
trial at MGH was halted after we had severe hypocellular
marrow after two of the first five patients were treated. So it's not so simple.
You can't just switch to another antigen and just keep moving forward.
But this strategy is still very much the
forefront right now in the lymphoma space.
And here are two different concepts of how to target.
So this
one on this side of the slide is a tandem design where
you have CD19, CD20 with this tether between.
So this is an example from Miltenyi's Zantacel.
And we also have a bicistronic where you're co-expressing
two different CARs, and they both can signal independent of each other.
They essentially take the construct of axicel and then add
this anti-CD20 with a 4-1BB postin, and both
are expressed. And I'll show you that data now.
So Zantacel has been tested in third line large B-cell lymphoma,
and we see that the overall response rate in this high-risk group
is 73% with a CR rate around half.
The PFS is around nine months, but importantly, we see pretty minimal
toxicity, about a 4% grade three ICANS and no grade three
CRS.
And it looks fairly durable.
So this is looking like it's going to move toward hopefully approval at some point.
But this is also now being tested in other areas.
So CNS lymphoma, both primary and secondary.
But the data from the Rav Shah group at Wisconsin has been pretty
impressive. So this is the data for Zantacel in mantle cell lymphoma.
These were fairly high-risk patients.
There's only 17 of them, but it was still looking very promising.
Almost half had TP53 aberrations.
One in
20% or so had complex karyotype. So overall, a very high-risk group.
And we're seeing these very durable
remissions. And you can see the PFS curve here.
Also notably, the rates of grade three, four
ICANS is fairly low compared to what we have.
So we'll need long-term follow-up.
There's a phase two trial enrolling now that's enrolling pretty quickly.
And there's a question of whether or not this can go after frontline instead of we
no longer do auto transplants pretty much in mantle cells.
So can we consolidate using the same kind of concepts that we see in myeloma that
we heard from Dr. Patel? So that's emerging now in mantle cell.
So this is the Kite-363.
Again, this is the bicistronic approach.
They enrolled some very high-risk patients across three different dose levels.
Dose level three was chosen for future development should it be
developed.
It's fairly standard. These are primary refractory or patients who've been
through multiple lines. At dose level three,
many patients required bridging.
I'll note that the LDH was elevated, so it's a marker of more aggressive
disease in about two-thirds of patients, which will be a
distinguishing feature compared to other trials. It's a fairly high-risk group.
And what they saw was a fairly high overall response rate of almost 90%.
CR rates that almost approached 80%.
This is in the CAR naive dose level three group.
But importantly,
we're seeing it's trending toward less neurotoxicity than we saw
with axicel. So even though we've added a new CAR and using
the same construct as axicel, because it's probably being triggered off a 4-1BB
construct, we're seeing less neurotox. That's at least a thought.
And so overall, this is looking promising, and the responses look durable.
We're seeing a six-month durable CR rate of almost 72%.
So this is encouraging, but it's small numbers.
We're going to see if that holds up with more
testing.There are also other groups.
So this is a CAR from Johnson & Johnson.
So this is, again, a sort of a tandem bispecific.
So it has a CD19 that's proximal to the signaling domain, and then
an anti-CD20 that recognizes two non-contiguous regions of
CD20.
Again, there was some dose escalation, dose finding.
They've picked 75 million CAR-positive cells to move forward with.
Again, a fairly high-risk group. LDH was elevated in about
one-third of patients. So overall, a pretty representative group.
Here again, we see very high response rates,
over 90%, approaching 100%. CR rates across all
these different groups
that were in the 75% to 80% range. So again, very
encouraging by just adding that second target, you're starting to
maximize some of the response
rates. Overall, we also see lower rates
of ICANS.
So, breakthrough is one patient out of the 26.
So overall, very encouraging. I'm excited about both the Kite option and
the J&J option. And there are other companies that also are emerging in the space.
But there are other targets. So, both MD Anderson
and MGH are now turning their attention to
CD79B.
We already have a drug approved, Polatuzumab, that works quite well.
And so they are now testing novel CARs in this space.
So a monotherapy and a
bispecific that's CD79B and CD19.
They're mostly in dose expansion cohorts, but these are ongoing
trials. There's also out of the City of Hope,
so Larry Kwok's group, and now the clinical trial's led by Elizabeth Budde,
targeting BAFF receptor.
The thought is that BAFF receptor signaling is required for B-cell survival, and
so it might mitigate the antigen loss as a mechanism of failure.
So the first patients have responded.
This is an ongoing trial that we're enrolling.
This is work that we did. So this is the Phase 1 trial before the cargo
experience. We took patients who had progressed
through a CD19 CAR and then gave them a second CAR, a CD22 targeting
CAR. So on average, it was their fifth line of therapy.
30% had never had a complete response to any prior lines, including multiple
patients who had eight prior lines of therapy.
We identified the recommended Phase 2 dose of one million CAR-positive cells.
But what was surprising, and to this day I'm still surprised, was the overall
response rate in this high-risk population was nearly 70%, with a CR rate of
53%.
And these have been durable. However, as patients survive, many of these patients
went on to develop secondary malignancies.
This is something that we're going to have to pay attention both in, I think, the
myeloma space and lymphoma space that you can cure them of their primary disease,
but from all the treatments they've been through, that damage accumulates, and so
we need to be vigilant of mostly myeloid malignancies.
This is our ongoing Phase 1 trial. This is now in many
other cohorts beyond large cell. So we have follicular, mantle cell,
a basket of others, including Burkitt's, marginal zone, hair cell, Waldenstrom's,
and we've now since added a large cell cohort since the cargo trial
stopped. What I can tell you is it's been very active.
In FL, every patient's had a complete response, and they've been quite durable.
Actually just had an 11th patient in response this past week.
So 11 for 11 so far. We've had two re-upses, both due
to CD22 downregulation. So that's not
surprising. Mantle cell, also very active, 100%
response rate. In overall, it's actually now 26 patients,
24 of 26 patients have responded, and the
CR rate is actually 22 of 26. And we've not seen
any Grade 3 or higher CRS, ICANS, or IECHS.
So, fairly impressive. We're excited about this CAR.
So just to summarize the antigen stories so far is that
there's concepts around either co-administration or sequential, like we saw in
myeloma. So do we just give a 19 by itself or do you give it together?
So we have a trial in leukemia where we're actually giving a 19
followed immediately by a 22. So that's one option.
These other alternatives are looking promising so far in the BAFF-R CAR,
high overall response rate, 100%, and these
79B trials are ongoing. We have bisectronic,
like the Kite-363.
I'll
get into more about another way of manufacturing this in a moment.
And then we have the bispecific tandem receptors.
And so there's multiple ones, and Ilteny's probably farthest along, probably will
get approved. But Johnson & Johnson's also looking very encouraging.
But there's a concept of make it faster.
So we heard about one in myeloma earlier.
And I just want to highlight two examples.
So this is the YTB-323.
This is where we took this
rapidly manufactured CAR,
and essentially treated patients like Zuma-12, for those who know that data.
Took high-risk frontline patients
with IPI scores that were three to five or double hit.
They had to have an interim PAT with a score of four to five,
meaning they had a
non-CR after two cycles, and then they had this CAR infused.
And it's a much smaller dose than we typically use.
So this is about 12.5 million CAR-positive cells as a flat
dose. And what we're excited to see is this progression-free survival
curve is quite impressive.
The overall response rate is quite high at almost 90%, and the CR rate
is 74%. And even when you look out six
months, 76% of patients are still holding on to that CR.
So that's quite impressive for this very high-risk group.
It actually looks very similar to Zuma-12.
And so this
type of data, both Zuma-12 and this trial, I think we're going to probably see
CAR therapy in the front line for large
cell.Kite also has
their rapid manufacturing approach.
So they took the 363
CAR and made Kite 753. The difference is in the manufacturing.
And they see here a much higher naive and stem
cell memory CD4 phenotypes in their products, both in
CD4 and CD8.
And so the data's just emerging, so I don't have any curves, but I can show you
the overall response rate and the CR rate are quite high, and this is very
encouraging. And this is in predominantly third-line patients.
So again, this rapid manufacturing makes it a little bit
easier to get patients treated quickly so they don't progress in the
meantime.
Another concept that's kind of simple, but it's not been tested thoroughly,
in my opinion, is what if you just give a higher dose
at the time of initial CAR? And so this is work
by Saurabh Dahia and Caroline Lee.
What they said is, "Well, we have a flat dose for axicell, but what if we
take patients with elevated LDH?" And historically, those patients have not
done as well. And we simply just give them a second bag with
just one lymph depletion.
So that's what they did. So they started, and they gave the standard of care
axicell, and then between seven and 14 days later,
without any extra lymph depletion, they gave a second dose.
So there was a safety run-in for the first three patients of a half million
CAR-positive cells, but now patients are getting the two million dose.
And they've fully enrolled 20 patients now on this trial, but I'll give you an
interim analysis.
And not surprising, this high-risk group, you have certain rates of CRS, so
everyone gets
non-severe CRS, and they have a certain rate of ICANS that's severe at
7%, so not surprising. But here's the data for the second infusion, which is
highlighted in these boxes here, is you actually have very
little severe toxicity effect, none,
and it's well managed. And so overall, it doesn't add too
much more to the toxicity. They're in the hospital only about
three to five extra days. But the overall response rate and CR rates
have been quite impressive. Again, these are high-risk patients, elevated LDH, and
you're seeing a 93% overall response rate and a nearly 80% complete
response, and those appear to be durable. We certainly need more follow-up.
It's only been seven months. But overall, this strategy looks encouraging.
I can't give a talk like this without at least mentioning armoring CARs.
And so this is one of many groups that have added
IL-18 to a humanized CD19.
And the data behind IL-18 is that it seems to enhance the T-cell
cytolytic function. It modulates the tumor microenvironment
with less MDSCs and affecting T reg function.
And so overall, we think it's allowing those T-cells to have a better
anti-tumor effect.
So they took this fourth-generation armored CAR, and they
enrolled patients who had already had a prior CAR-19.
So these are, again, pretty refractory cases and treated now with this
new humanized IL-18-secreting CAR, and an 81 overall
response rate is quite impressive.
And half of those patients developed a complete response.
And so while it's not always durable, you certainly get some
benefit, and this might permit patients who are eligible to go to an
allotransplant or some other strategy such as that.
But overall, we've not seen a lot of high-grade ICANS, although there are higher
rates of grade 3 CRS, and in having conversations with some of
these folks, it looks more like an HLH kind of phenomenon.
So there's some more biology that needs to be sorted out, particularly around
IL-18, but the concept of armoring your CAR or enhancing
the CAR by changing the microenvironment or enhancing the T-cells will
be, I think, further explored.
With the time left, I'm going to turn my attentions to ALL.
I'm grateful now that we have two different options,
and these have been transformative.
Patients have had fairly durable remissions who are very high risk.
But I'd like to point out that many of these patients have received
an allotransplant prior to their CAR or an
allotransplant after their CAR.
And so while I know this is supposed to be a CAR T-cell doc, I also do transplant,
and I just want to highlight this really cool strategy that I find
very exciting.
So at Stanford, a work by Rob Negrin and Everett Meyer has
demonstrated this novel approach.
So typically with transplant, we harvest a bag of cells,
and we just infuse those into the patient.
But within that bag are cells that probably are helpful and harmful.
So what many years of research have shown is that you can then,
using high-speed sorters, sort out the stem cells, sort out T
regulatory cells, and then sort out T cons, or essentially T effector
cells. And by fusing the stem cells and the T regulatory cells is you
actually allow those T regulatory cells to hone to the different tissues
and set up a regulatory environment, so
it mitigates the risk of graft versus host.
And then you still need a few of those T effector cells or T cons to allow for
engraftment. So that's why you still need to give a dose of T-cells.
So we've now had randomized trials comparing this T
reg, T con allograft approach called Orca T.
And in a randomized trial, we see significantly less grade
3, 4 acute graft versus host, moderate to severe chronic graft versus host,
and then we did not compromise relapse-free
survival. So the composite endpoint between
acute and chronic and relapse-free survival is significantly better,
and hopefully by the summer, this will be approved for the treatment
of leukemias.
But the question came up, "Well, what if you add a CAR?" And so work by Melody
Smith has shown that if you add a CAR, it
actually can contribute to reducing graft versus host.
And on this slide, we see that a lot of patients still
relapse, and we also know that patients will still relapse after an
allo.So what if we take this engineered
graft and we had a CD19, CD20 CAR, and this is our data
from leukemia patients. And it's a high response rate, but not particularly
durable. Well, what if we combine the two?
So that's what was done. We took that same strategy of infusing the stem cells and
the TruRegs on day zero. But in addition to those T
cons, we infuse a donor-derived. So
the donor cells are not affected by all that kino.
So these are more functional T cells.
So a donor-derived allo CAR that targets CD19, CD20, and then the
next day we only give single-agent tacrolimus, no post-transplant
methotrexate, no PTSI. And there was a dose
escalation of what cell dose, and so we've arrived at dose level three.
And here's the data. And so this is
a manuscript that we're going to submit shortly as a group.
So this is work by Laurie Muffley and Melody Smith.
And here's your overall survival and disease-free survival line.
There's not even a curve.
There has been no relapses.
Everybody who is MRD positive has become MRD negative.
So at the latest follow-up, some of the patients took maybe over a year in some
cases. All the patients have achieved these durable remissions.
But what's really impressive to me is the rates of acute and chronic graft versus
host. We had a single patient with skin GVHD that required some
cream. That's it.
No other graft versus host.
And then for chronic, we've had two patients. Sorry, three patients.
Most were skin. So overall, what we're finding is by
combining an ORCA T-engineered graft with a
donor-derived CD19, CD22 CAR, is we can have these
very durable without
GVHD type of survival. So overall, this is now
going to be tested in other areas.
We're developing a protocol in lymphoma,
and I think this is also being opened for myeloma at a
site as well.
So in summary, the key takeaways is target something new.
We saw many new targets.
Make it quick, make it rapid. Infuse it twice, armor it,
combine it. So I've just showed you the data, you're combining allo
CAR with allo transplant. And then the two things that I didn't have a lot of time
to talk about is, is there a role for allogeneic CAR T?
There's actually just a press release for alpha three.
And so we saw that these were patients who had MRD positive
disease at the end of frontline, and they were given this allogeneic
CAR. And so far, at one of the interim
analysis, they met it. And so that's exciting.
It may be a novel strategy to take high-risk patients and give them a fairly
well-tolerated allogeneic CAR.
And then we don't have the in vivo data that we see in myeloma, so I'm excited to
see that. There's many companies moving into this space, and so I think that'll be
next year's talk. And I look forward to seeing all of that data between now and
then.
So thank you for your attention, and that's my talk.
Thank you. Any questions for Dr. Frank?
Okay.
From
all your...
I always thought that at least right now, we do
not know the best approach to really target two
antigens. And so from your lymphoma experience, can you just
comment on that again?
Which kind of design you believe has the most
promise or
how, because I think it's a...
We struggle also, and I would mention my talk also in ALL, how to really best do
that.
I'm going to be honest and say, I don't know.
I think it's very complicated, and I think the specific CAR or
CARs that you're putting into a cell can matter.
There's also some practical purposes, right?
So if you're making two different products, so if I want to make a CAR A and CAR B
infuse them both, I think that's a little more expensive.
So for practical reasons, I think we're going to stick to one cell, and
then whether or not you want to put a bicistronic, tricistronic,
there were technical limitations, but now companies are starting to put three
different CARs in.
I think it's going to come down to the specific constructs to a certain degree.
And there's no preclinical model that I think is going to be satisfactory.
So it ultimately is going to be build the best version you think and get them into
patients and we'll find out together.
We're seeing the J&J data, which is more of a tandem,
and the Kite data with 753 and 63 looking very remarkably
similar. I can't distinguish the two with the numbers we have so far.
So both look promising. At one point, I would've said one or the other, but now I'm
humbled and back to I don't know again.
Okay. One question.
Hi. You probably said this, but I probably missed it.
What is currently the best approach against CLL,
and does it depend on what kind of CLL, like mutated,
unmutated, 13Q, 17P, et cetera?
Yeah. So I actually didn't include CLL in the talk.
I think CARs have struggled a little bit in the CLL space. We do have an approval.
So we do have lyso cell approved, and about half the patients
respond, about 20% durably.
I think that
the way I'm going to talk about it is I don't think CARs by
themselves are the solution yet.
Actually, one of the trials we're developing is for those high-risk CLL patients is
to do this graft engineer plus CAR.
Because part of the reason CARs don't work very well in CLL is the T cells are
pretty dysfunctional. So if you combine that with the high-risk
mutational profiles of the tumor cells,
I don't think we're going to see durable remissions in Richter's or CLL,
and I think we need to go one beyond.
So, can't make promises I can't keep, but I do think that
this alloDonor-derived CAR is something that we're
really taking seriously. I think that would be a better approach for really the
high-risk patients.
Those durably responding patients for the BTKIs and the
BCL2 inhibitors, those patients are going to do very well.
But those high-risk patients need something more than we have now.
All right.
One question.
Yeah, nice talk. I get to learn a lot about the lymphoma
landscape. So I have a question for an
allogeneic,
I think allotherapeutic.
They have allo product, CD19 allo product.
Their allo cell expansion is not that high.
That's why they target a low tumor burden.
So you talk about one product, it's ORCA-T, right?
You combine the
donor product that's kind of have lots of
stem cell feature. I'm just wondering, how's
the
allo rejection for those kind of cells from not
exactly CAR T, but it's HSCT,
something like that with a stem
cell feature? Thank you.
So you raised two different issues and one is allo CAR.
Yeah.
And those are sort of off-the-shelf,
derived from healthy donors. And there are a number of companies who have
tested those, but those have largely fallen out of favor because of the lack of
durable responses to them. And so your point is well taken.
I actually think that the Alpha-3 data is encouraging and because
I think that they can pick off the last MRD.
But there were some interesting data around some of those allo CARs that if you
were somewhat HLA-matched, those CARs expanded better,
persisted better, and actually those patients had similar, I would
argue, responses with less toxicity
to the autologous CARs. So
if it wasn't for the in vivo CARs emerging, I think we would have
probably pursued that
kind of concept of matching HLH with our patients. So that's the allo CAR space.
With the graft engineer ORCA-T approach,
that's just one example. Essentially what I'm arguing is
that historically, allo transplant gets a bad rap.
It causes a lot of graft versus host, but that field is moving quickly as well.
We have a lot of novel graft engineering approaches, and we have
ours at Stanford, but other groups have them as well, where you can deplete certain
cell types that cause trouble
to create a safer graft.
And when you do that,
we still worry about relapse. You still have about a 20% relapse
rate,
at best.
So the idea is can we add something to your allo transplant
to reduce that relapse risk?
So for ALL, it's fairly easy because we can target CD19, which is not on the
stem cell.
For AML, it's pretty hard because the AML targets are also on the stem
cells.
So to be really honest with you, I think what we're going to need to do is start
modifying our stem cells, and that strategy has been tried.
You can deplete CD33, for example, and then you can add a CD33 CAR.
So this strategy of using allo transplant and allo CAR, or
donor-derived CAR,
I think might emerge over the next few years.
At least I hope it does, because it means it's working.
So for those who are interested in that kind of space,
go read about Melody Smith's work,
and Laurie Muffley, who's given a bunch of talks on this concept.
All right. Thank you again.
Now?
All right.
I will now
try to summarize approaches for CAR T-cell therapy
for pediatric blood cancers, and these
are my disclosures.
So what I would try to do, cover CD19 CAR T-cells for
BLL because there's really no lymphoma or myeloma
in pediatrics. Then talk about CAR T-cell
approaches for TLL, and then the last part of my talk touch on
efforts to develop CAR T-cell therapy for pediatric AML.
If you look at the landscape of CD19 CAR T-cells,
Kymriah or tisagenlecleucel was the first FDA-approved CAR product.
On the left is Shannon Maun's pivotal study.
But then in the CIBMTR database, there is actually now data,
and even the real-world data for pediatric ALL I think looks
very promising. And I think another interesting feature is, since we had
much longer a CAR product for pediatric
ALL, FDA approved than for adults, we actually have
infused more pediatrics ALL patients than adults, which
is much, much rarer than adult ALL.
And that probably will change in the next couple of
years. As mentioned already
by the previous speakers,
CAR T-cell therapy comes with toxicities.
But I would say that at least the very common
one we can manage right now very well
with available agents. And at least in pediatrics,
the interesting thing is being able to manage
certain sets of toxicities have highlighted others.
One include HLH, but the other really also
include inflammatory toxicities on the marrow
leading to prolonged pancytopenias, and these are
active areas of research, figuring out mechanism
and also
approaches to intervene.
Another
really important topic is how to
treat or can CAR T-cell be used to treat
CNS relapse, and they are
alreadyA member from the audience asked what about
differentiating it to bispecific T-cell engagers?
Clearly, CAR T cells can penetrate into the
CSF, and using radiation for
pediatric patients with relapsed CNS disease has really
lots of long-term sequelae. And this is a study which was
conducted by the UPenn group and
presented at ASH last year, and I think it's very, very
encouraging that you can actually use CD19 CAR T cells to
eradicate CNS relapse for BLL
without requiring radiation.
We've also recently looked at the question, do
CAR T cells persist in the CNS of Kymriah
patients? And we looked up to a year, and to me, it's
actually quite amazing that you can detect in the CSF
of patients, even without CNS disease, CAR
T cells for a very long period of time.
This is associated with pleocytosis. I think that is well known.
Mechanism is not clear. However,
actually five years ago was a high-impact study
highlighting that actually CD19 is expressed on the mural
cells of the blood vessels within the
CNS, and you probably have to
postulate that some of these cells remain leaky, or
the blood-brain barrier is a little bit leaky, and therefore, white blood
cells are present within the CSF long-term.
There is no correlation between white blood cells and qPCR level,
but there seems to be a cutoff. If you have three white
blood cells in CSF, your likelihood of having
CD19 CAR T cells present is lower, significantly lower than you
have higher. So that is probably, I would say, an
advantage versus the use of T-cell
engagers that we can protect. CD19
CAR T cells can be used to protect patients from a CNS
relapse, which I would say remains a significant
challenge as we are trying to reduce therapy for pediatric ALL.
So what are risk factors of therapeutic failure?
And not surprisingly, prior targeted CD19
therapy, disease burden, and cytogenetics.
Conditioning regimen. There have been lots of data, at least in
the pediatric space now, looking very carefully at
fludarabine kinetics. And you metabolize
fludarabine faster the younger you are,
and
two groups independently have highlighted that you need a certain AUC
to have optimal responses, and several
groups, including ours, have now studies where
we actually age-adjust the fludarabine dose so that younger
patients have the same fludarabine exposure as
adolescents and older patients.
Then the level of achieved remission that was again also
mentioned for lymphoma and myeloma.
But in pediatric, it's clear you really must need to get to very
deep remission by NGS, less than one in a million, and if
you achieve that, your risk of recurrence is very
low. And then at least for
ALL, persistent is key.
Without persistence, and where the cutoff is, is
not clearly established. Most of us
are looking at studies if you have functional B-cell aplasia,
at least for six months after CD19 CAR T-cell
infusion, your risk of subsequent relapse is
extremely low.
If you have recovery of your B cells within three months,
your risk is very, very high.
So what is the role of allotransplant?
Already mentioned by Matt, many patients who
receive CAR T-cell therapy for ALL undergo
allotransplant, especially those early.
And if you actually carefully look in the literature, it is
not clear to sort out for at least for
BBBCARs. Clearly, there seems to be
also trend-wise in very high-risk patients who achieved CR,
if they go to allotransplant, that they have better outcomes.
In contrast, for CARs with CD28 zeta
domain, I would say it's clearly established that if
you have received a CD28 CAR for
BLL, and to achieve a CR, you have to go
to an allotransplant to have long-term
remissions.
So
how do we now practically decide
what to do with a patient? And unfortunately, there is, at least right
now, no established algorithm, and I'm the
first one to admit it's a little bit center-dependent.
However, clearly
after transplant, monitoring very closely B cells, how
long are the patient's B cells play,
what is the MRD status,
really can help you decide if a patient should have
allogeneic transplant as consolidative therapies.
Then, of course, the patient characteristic, ongoing
comorbidities, and of course, also in pediatrics, the
patient-caregiver preferences play a big role
in making the final plan. Then, of course,
disease status. CAR T, did the patient had previous CAR
Ts? Is the patient post-allotransplant and
relapsed? And based on these issues, we really then
try to come up with aplan for these patients.
Nirali Shah actually has a study where we now
systematically are looking at this to really provide
evidence-based decision pathways how to
manage pediatric patients who received
CD19 CAR T cells and achieved
complete CR.
So similar to
other diseases, antigen escape and limited persistence
are the main mechanisms of failure.
And already, as mentioned by Matt, I find it actually rather
fascinating. There are multiple mechanisms how
malignant B cells can evade
immune
escape, that can all these shortened splice
variant. Of course, the most, I would say, feared
thing which can happen in BLL is that you have a lineage switch, then
the patient relapses with AML. And then several
groups have highlighted that if there is this unfortunate event that
the BLL blast in the product is genetically modified with a
CAR, you get, of course, immunoscape because the CD19 is
cloaked. And then while that has been not reported so much
in pediatric ALL, as mentioned already by Matt, in lymphoma,
antigen downregulation is also a significant mechanism.
In pediatric ALL, as for lymphoma, different
approaches have been tried, infusing of two CAR products,
co-expression, and bispecific CARs.
And the initial results have all been published.
But again, if I ask Matt the questions, the same what
is true in lymphoma also holds up for pediatric
BLL. At present, the best strategy how to
target CD19 and
CD22 for pediatric BLL remains
elusive, and I'm hopeful that some of the products which are being
currently tested in the adult world will also be tested
in pediatric patients in the future.
So what about persistence?
Again, you can think now about combinatorial therapies
to enhance products which are currently FDA approved.
You can go back to the drawing board to
fiddle with the CAR design, and I think the best example is really auto cell,
which uses an SCV with a high off rate, which already
has received approval for adult BLL,
and the pediatric study is currently ongoing.
And then, of course, you can introduce second genetic modification,
like for example, cytokine and including
IL-18.
We've been very interested in epigenetic reprogramming,
and I do not want to spend too much time on T pathology, but in the end,
cells are in a naive-like state and then in
the presence of antigen, lose their plasticity
and end up in an exhausted state. And what has been
very,
I would say, important also in immune study is this concept
that there is a
precursor-exhausted cells, also called TPECs,
which is in the end a branch point where you are able to go back
up to a more functional state. But if you're beyond the TPEC
state, you
are permanently exhausted. So that has been
established very well in immune models, but
also in
human studies. And we've been interested in it because of work
from Ben Youngblood initially at
St. Jude, where he had shown in preclinical model, if you
delete the EMT3A in post-thymic T
cells,
these remain responsive to checkpoint
blockade. And if you delete the EMT3A in post-thymic T
cells, there is no risk of an increased malignancy, which, of course, is
very different if you do it in pre-thymic T cells or in
HSCs.
They've also then looked very carefully in one of our clinical study and
asked the question, "What happens to even
effective CD19 CAR T cells once they are infused in
patients?" And if you look in the GMP product, they have what is called a
multipotency index, which is based on genes which are
regulated by EMT3A, and the products actually have a rather
high multipotency index. But then within a few weeks
after infusion, there is a significant decline
in plasticity of the infused cells,
even in those where patients received the CR.
And therefore, we are now developing a study where we actually would
like to do both. We want target two antigens to
prevent immunoscape, but then also delete
the EMT3A to really enhance the
persistent of CAR T cells.
So just to summarize this part of my talk, there are several
FDA-approved products.
There are now novel auto CAR Ts on the horizon.
There is this effort of exploring allo CAR T cells and of course,
also other immune cell products. And then, of course, in
vivo CAR T manufacturing is also on the horizon.
So now I would like to switch gear and briefly talk about CAR Ts
for T LL.
Very similar to B cell LL, most approaches have
focused on lineage targets, CD5 and
CD7. And of course, there is a problem because the T cells
also express these, and there is fratricide.And there are now
numerous ways to prevent
fratricide from happening. You can do gene-based editing.
You can retain CD7 or CD5 within the
cell. You can naturally select
CD5 or CD7-negative
T cells, and then, of course, you can pharmacologically inhibit CAR T
cell function during manufacturing.
And for CD7-targeted therapies, I would say
the response rates have been remarkable across multiple
studies using auto as well as allo product.
However, they come with significant toxicity because
these patients are severely
immunocompromised, and the non-relapsed mortality
in some of these studies is up to 20%.
So looking ahead, I would say there are two
challenges we have to overcome,
is really how to deal with contaminating TLL blasts within the
product, and I think there using short-lived allo CAR T
products might be the solution because
also they persist shorter,
and we might prevent some of the toxicity.
And then, of course, there are numerous engineering approach where we can
now use on/off switches,
Boolean gating to really limit the
activity of the infused product.
Now in the last few minutes, I would like to touch on the CAR Ts for
AML.
Clearly, there is an antigen dilemma because most targets
are either expressed on mature or on stem
cells within the myeloid lineage.
But over the last couple of years, other targets have emerged
which are not expressed on HSCs or mature
myeloid cells, which include CD70, folate
receptor one, mesothelin. So I believe that
finally there are now targets which
do not cause
prolonged neutropenia. But then in
contrast to leukemias, the AML
microenvironment presents a significant hurdle,
and it really looks to me like a solid tumor
microenvironment, which is extremely immune inhibitory with
myeloid-derived suppressor cells, regulatory T cells, and
other inhibitory cells.
Nevertheless, there's been tremendous activity in this
space, going back to early studies more than 15
years ago using Lewis Y as a target
antigen. But if you just look, and
this summarizes all clinical studies,
the response rate really have been low,
and these low response rate are actually paired with a quite
high incidence of significant CRS
and
ICANS,
which highlights that these cells tend to cause more
inflammation than having anti-AML activity.
This highlights our own experience with the
CD123 CAR T cell product,
a study led by Swati Naik and Paulina Velasquez.
And there's definitely activity, and this is highlighted here in the PET
scan of a patient who had disseminated extramedullary disease,
who had a complete CR or disappearance of all
her PET-positive lesions for three months.
So clearly there is activity. We only have to figure
out how to improve the activity and reduce
toxicities.
Another big issue in the AML space has been since a
lot of centers do their own studies,
how do we compare these
single-center academic studies?
And
Swati Naik, together with Sar Gill,
formed a working group which have now met
for three years in a row and
published a consensus statement last year highlighting the
clinical challenges as well as the CAR T cell challenges,
and really has recommended a harmonization
since it's very difficult to do multi-center studies, at least from an
academic perspective. Could at least trial reporting be
harmonized? And also the trial conduct in regards to
lympho-depleting chemotherapy, in regards to correlative
studies, so that in the end these single studies could be
compared and we can really accelerate
progress in the space.
Finally,
of course, there are a multitude of improvement strategies, and that is a
last year review published by Marion Zuklaiva and Michelle Sadelain,
which highlights engineering strategies where you can now
start about ways to overcome on-target
toxicity,
ICANS, CRS, AML immune escape,
and then also really trying to target AML
microenvironment to improve
outcomes. So to summarize my talk,
for CD19 CAR T cells, we really need better predictive
biomarkers. This question how to prevent relapse is still
open. And then this question, as I already mentioned, is what is
the best therapeutic approach for patients who received a
deep remission?
And then for TLL,
the response rates are fabulous, but the side effects, I think we have to
manage the side effects better. And then for AML, we really
are still in the stage where we really have to improve efficacy
without increasing the risk of on-target and off-cancer
toxicity.And with this, I just want to
highlight St. Jude and our cell therapy program,
where we really try very hard to translate novel
therapeutics into early-phase clinical studies.
Thank you so much for your attention.
Any questions?
Thank you. Great talks. You touched briefly on the fludarabine
question and the variable AUC. I wonder whether you and the other
panel members would like to comment on future lymphodepleting
regimens that may avoid fludarabine.
I can probably-- I know in the lymphoma space,
bendamustine
psi has been
explored, but I think the latest data highlights that bendamustine
cyclophosphamide is inferior to flu psi.
And
coming from the solid tumor, we actually have a small
cohort of patients which we only gave fludarabine,
and clearly the expansion of the CAR T cells
was much lower. So I think for right now, I would say flu psi
is the golden standard, and as you know, there is,
why is the fludarabine dose rather constant?
Cyclophosphamide doses vary a little bit on the disease
target. I don't know if you want to comment.
So I agree with your
conclusions around the bendamustine.
As I think in the field, we feel that it's probably inferior, but
to play devil's advocate, it's based on
retrospective data. We
were forced actually at Stanford to
use bendamustine when we ran out of fludarabine.
And actually, that cohort did remarkably similar, but it's 27 patients, so
I'm not going to hang my hat on it too much.
But if you look retrospectively,
and I think there is some bias about who gets benda.
There's data from Natalie Grover's work, I think that she used benda and didn't
work very well on a Hodgkin's car. So there's enough data that says benda isn't as
good.
I think the answer is probably that we're moving toward in vivo, where we're
probably not going to be-- it may be a less exciting
topic, although I don't think everything's
moving toward
in vivo, but I think there are a lot will, where we're trying to get away from
lymphodepleting strategies. So I think that's probably the best answer,
is that's where the field's headed.
Beautiful talk, Steve. Congratulations. Two questions.
One, everybody's talking about the early usage
of CAR T cells. So in ALL, so seems to be that it's
very difficult with around 90-plus percent of the cure rate.
So what is your vision how you are going to integrate CD19?
Is this going to move forward and maybe shorten the
maintenance treatment or do it post-induction?
So that will be first question. And
second question is,
what is your feeling, we are talking about the in vivo.
Do you see in vivo as a practical approach to
hematologic malignancies with circulating tumor cells like ALL, for
instance?
I think at least in pediatric ALL, we are
considering
should we really at least try to move it into CR1?
As you all know, the incorporating upfront BlinA,
has changed the ALL field dramatically in the last
couple of years. And we really, I think also now have to wait, because the
initial response rate is also great when some of these patients relapse
because they still express CD19. So I think there how to
place BlinA versus CD19 CAR T cells,
I'm not sure. Clearly, therefore, I highlighted the
CNS story. There, I strongly believe that,
not only I, but investigators strongly believe that CD19
CAR T cells clearly have an advantage over the use
of
blinatumomab.
In regards to in vivo for
leukemia, the question is really long-term persistence.
So I do not believe that, at least mRNA
versus LNPs are the answer.
And I think we have to,
I think, continue to also to work on ex vivo approaches.
And
I'm being asked all the time, I strongly believe if we
work out, for example, what is the best second genetic
modification or other modification in an ex vivo
approach, that will then inform the best
approaches for in vivo. Because I still
struggle with,
I cannot see a scenario where we, let's say, provide
a CAR and a cytokine if we don't
have vetted that very carefully in
this ex vivo model. So,
I cannot look in the future. I don't know what's going to happen in a decade from
now, but I strongly believe that continued work on
ex vivo approaches will, in the end, inform the future,
whatever it is, either ex vivo or in vivo.
All right. Just one last question. Okay.
Okay. Great talk. Thank you. I just have a question about
the lineage switch that occurs after CD19 CAR T
therapy. What is currently being done?
Are there additional therapies that can be done to address this, or what are we
doing to address that lineage switch?
It depends a little bit on the underlying mutations
of the
causing genetic fusion.
ButI think you cannot
prevent it, so to speak. Right now, we do not exclude these patients who
are at higher risk from receiving CD19 CAR T cells, but we just
have to, so to speak, approach as
if it happens.
One last question.
Thank you.
I just have a basic question. Is
there any alternative for CAR T? For example, take a
horse protein and then fuse it with a foreign protein, like foreign
antigen.
Can we make a antitumor response, like making antitumor
response?
But that in the end is blinatumomab.
It's a T-cell engager where you, in the end, fuse a single-chain variable
for CD19 to an activating
SCV for CD3. So yes, and of course, now
with AI, you can probably do it all in a small synthetic molecule.
So I would say yes, it's possible.
One last question.
Very nice talk. I actually have a couple questions, but you kind of referred to-- I
just want to hear two comments about, one is can you refer to
T-cell engager, like TCEs. What do you think about the future
lies like a TCE? It's a little bit cheaper, but there are probably some caveats for
the CAR T. Another one that I would love to hear about is whether CAR-T
strategy, you have like a gate, like AND gate, for example, by specifically this
kind of style and going onto CAR T. Would you think that would be a
future for
one of options, for example?
Well, I
think, this question, engager versus CAR T
cells, it would probably depend on the clinical situation in the end.
So
I would
say it's really not black or white.
It's like with all,
I think areas in medicine, we'll have
hopefully lots of therapeutic option and then depending
on the patient, we will have a specific approach.
And for one patient it might be blinai, for a patient, for
instance, in pediatric who has CNS relapse, it would be a CAR product.
So I really don't see that they're compete, of
course, to a certain extent compete, but one will not take
one over, so they both will exist. And,
I think the other question, I think there, I'm actually very
hopeful all these Boolean gating, SynNotch system,
everything, all these very exciting technologies have
not been broadly tested in the clinic.
And yes, of course, wouldn't be nice, for example,
if you could infuse CD19 CAR T cells,
then
after six months, we could turn off the CAR, patients could get their B
cells back, would be no longer IVIG dependent.
And then if MRD testing is positive, you just turn on the CAR
again. So I really believe that there the future
is still ahead of us, and I'm still very
excited that some of these really novel engineering approaches
will continue to revolutionize how we can take care of these
patients.
But anyway. All right. I think we're at an end, so I would like to thank
everyone for staying. Again, I would like to thank my co-speakers
again, and thank you all for coming early on a Saturday morning.